want to know the best tip in demon souls
go and
fall off a cliff
i'm serious when you get back to the
nexus after defeating a boss
go and walk off a ledge killing yourself
in this way is a good idea because of
something called
world tendency a mechanic in demon souls
where the world itself
reacts to your success or failure in
human form
kill a boss and that world takes a step
towards
white world tendency making enemies
weaker die
in human form and your world takes a
step backwards into black world tendency
making enemies tougher
you can see how white or black your
world tendency is in this menu screen
and how bright the eyes are will give
you an indication of where that world's
tendency is at
so when you're in human form you have
all of your health but if you die
then you enter soul form where your
health is at fifty percent
the plus side in soul form your deaths
no longer affect
world tendency so that's why we die in
the nexus
this way we stay in soul form and we
keep our world tendency white
because every time you kill a boss world
tendency goes even further towards pure
white and
if you never die in human form then your
world will eventually just hit pure
white world tendency by the time
you defeat the final boss which also
unlocks a bunch of special events for
each world
and after your pure white world tendency
in a finished world you can consider
moving your world tendency back towards
black world tendency
if there's any pure black events that
you want to experience
now that's not to say that you should
never go into human form
just be aware that when you do you run
the risk of making your world
harder but if you feel like you want to
roll the dice and get that extra health
to kill a boss
then pop a stone of ephemeral eyes and
just go for it it's a lot more exciting
to play demon souls in this way
and while you're human you also open
yourself up to more
online play to summon other players into
your world for help
you'll need to be human look on the
ground for blue summoning signs that
other players have placed
and summon the phantoms that look strong
if you want to be
the phantom and help other players then
you'll need the blue eye stone that you
get from the maiden in black
after defeating the first boss phalanx
use this in soul form
in a part of the world where you think
people will see your sign
and other players will be able to touch
your mark when they're in human form and
summon you into their world as
assistance
help them defeat the boss of the level
and you'll get souls
and your body back alternatively you can
also invade human players to get your
body back
the item you'll need for this is the
black eye stone and you'll need to kill
a nameless npc black phantom to receive
one
so good candidates for this are the
black phantom in the first stage of
latria right before the first boss
or the black phantom in the second stage
of the shrine of storms who
is in the pit underneath the first
reaper you'll see
picking a good server is also important
now you can go back to the title screen
and choose a server there
choose one that has low latency but be
aware that at launch the popular servers
are under pretty heavy load so be aware
that the lowest latency might not match
your area
but before you engage in online play
you're going to want to know the basics
and
the first tip of any souls game has to
be this keep your shield up
out of all the souls games though i feel
like demon souls actually puts
more emphasis on the shield than any
other and
there are a ton of enemies that you can
simply defeat by attacking after they
bounce off your shield
the shield i'd recommend at the
beginning is the heater shield
which you can get from the blacksmith in
the nexus it blocks a hundred percent of
physical damage
but not all shields do this so be sure
to check their stats so you don't take
chip damage this is a light shield but
if you want to go for a tanky build then
you can choose a heavier shield and you
won't take as much of a stamina hit when
you block
drop your shield in between enemy
attacks to regenerate stamina
and always rotate around your enemies so
you can backstab them wherever possible
you're invulnerable while you're doing
this so it's great when you're
surrounded by multiple enemies
if you time it right you can also keep
some enemies in a backstab
loop of course if you're a magic build
you might rarely find yourself in a
position to backstab
since you'll be attacking at range and
wanting to get away whenever enemies get
too close
you'll often find yourself just rolling
instead there are a couple of frames
here when you hit
the roll button where you're completely
invincible so
you can either use those to roll through
an attack or simply
roll out of range before an attack can
hit you rolling
like most things consumes stamina but
it's often a better way to avoid damage
than blocking is
especially when your stamina is low in
demon souls also you'll only get a fast
roll if you stay below
50 equipment burden visible here
fat rolling at 51 equipment burden is a
world worse than being at 49 so
try to just stay shy of 50 unless you're
fully committed to a heavy
tanky build which can work as well
leveling endurance will help you
with your equipment burden but in demon
souls no matter what stat you level
your defense will actually be raised
meaning your character will always feel
more powerful as you level
more so than in any other souls game if
you're still not sure which stats to
level
consider subscribing because soon i'll
do a video covering great early game
builds
but until then you really can't go wrong
with vitality and endurance
to level your stats you'll have to
exchange your souls with the maiden in
black who is found in the nexus
and one of the funnier quirks of demon
souls unless it happens to you
is that you can actually lose these
levels in a ton of different ways
for example if you invade a host and
fall to your death
then how embarrassing you lose a level
if you invade a host and willingly leave
their world or if they kick you out with
the banished miracle
that's rude you lose a level some bosses
even drain your soul levels
but they won't spoil who the stat you'll
lose is the one that's the highest
relative to your character's starting
stats
and unlike other souls games spells
don't require a certain amount of faith
or magic to cast
they just require you to have enough mp
and spell slots which can be expanded by
leveling your intelligence stat
your spell effectiveness still scales
with these stats though so
if you're a magic build then target
magic with some intelligence
and if you're a faith build target faith
with some intelligence as well
in this game you would tune your spells
at spell vendors and to get your mp back
you'll want to use the spice consumables
found throughout the world
when you do inevitably take damage
you'll need to heal
demon souls healing system is kind of
like bloodborne's where you find healing
items out in the world
and while there is a smaller cap on how
much grass you can carry in the remake
you can still brute force a lot of
encounters by being prepared
with good healing in the original
inventory management was a nightmare but
in the remake you can also send all
those items back to stockpile thomas
with the click of a button
always do this and make sure to go back
to him often to retrieve your
overstocked healing items
and the amount of grass heals
corresponds to the cycles of the moon
in their names so crescent grass heals
the least
and full moon grass heals the most try
to put them on your quick menu
in that order but remember if you hold
down on the d-pad
it will instantly take you to the first
item on your quick bar so
maybe make that your most powerful grass
so you can get to it
in a pinch you'll find yourself using
crescent moon grass a lot between fights
since it's the cheapest and easiest to
find but during battle you might want to
equip the more valuable ones to help you
stay alive
the absolute best consumable vendor in
this game weirdly enough
is patches who sells a wide variety in
the nexus for the cheapest price
you can find him here after one of his
two encounters out in the world
one encounter is in the second stage of
stonefang tunnels
where you turn left at the fork take the
elevator down
and follow the narrow cave to this cliff
face he's on the left the other
encounter is in the second stage of the
shrine of storms
below the first reaper you would have
seen in the cutscene after either of
these he'll appear in the nexus and if
he ever disappears from the nexus then
you might have to go and complete the
other encounter that you didn't finish
first if you don't have enough souls for
levels or consumables then
you can try to farm for a while one of
my favorite spots is in the first stage
of the shrine of storms
and it's actually a really good place to
practice your parries as well
the skeletons take a ton of damage from
blunt damage type weapons
so check your inventory for something
blunt you can use but if you don't have
anything
just pummel them with your fists instead
they do heaps of damage
use your shield to block their attacks
and then hit them as many times as you
can
or parry them until they're dead if you
have an upgraded bow
another great spot is in the second
level of the shrine of storms
where you can easily take out the reaper
to harvest the souls from all of his
apparitions
the type of damage your weapon does feel
so important in demon souls because
as we just saw some enemies are very
weak or very resistant to either blunt
slashing or piercing damage there's the
tough scales of the miners or the plate
armor of the soldiers for example which
can be easily pierced or crushed those
in the valley of defilement are
incredibly weak to fire
and those with light armor tend to be
weak to slashing attacks
you can sort of use your common sense
here experiment a bit as well
and you'll find that in demon souls a
lot can be overcome
with the right strategies and thinking
critically about the rpg elements
rather than just using raw skill
blacksmith baldwin
is where you can repair and upgrade your
weapons and we'll talk about powerful
weapons soon
in a video titled overpowered early but
until then
know that you should come back here
often to see if you can upgrade your
weapons with the shards that you'll find
throughout the world
most of your basic weapons use sharp
stone largely found in the stone fang
tunnels and in boletaria
and there are honestly too many other
shard types and demon souls to mention
here so
i'll just put a wiki link in the
description that said you can only
upgrade your weapon to plus five in the
nexus
and to upgrade it further you'll need to
find blacksmith ed
ed is located at the bottom of the
rotating platforms at the very beginning
of the stonefang tunnels
to get those platforms moving simply
progress through the first level in
a linear fashion until you get to this
laneway with lava lizards in a room to
your right
proceed straight along this lane break
through all the rubble
and turn the lever on the cliff face
below
is blacksmith ed who can take boss souls
and turn them into unique boss weapons
once you give him a red hot demon soul
which you get from flame lurker later on
in this world
once you have it give it to ed and come
back whenever you get a new boss soul to
see what you can craft
for example phalanx's lead soul can be
combined with a plus seven short spear
to create the scraping sphere and
there's tons more like this find a
weapon
and a shield that suits you and when
you're confident in them
spend the time upgrading them at
blacksmith ed doing this will make you
so much more powerful
than a couple of levels will the order
in which you do levels
will affect how powerful you feel as
well each world has at least
three stages which you unlock in
sequential order and
the further you get into a world the
harder it will get
as well therefore try to clear the first
couple of stages of each world
before progressing too deep into any
particular one
this will give you a mental break from
difficult areas and it will allow your
character to become much more powerful
off of the early areas if you're worried
that you've died too many times in human
form and
you've ruined your world and your game
by making it black world tendency
don't worry let me introduce you to this
cute little guy
the primeval demon there's one of these
in each world
and while they always appear in the same
place they'll only spawn when you're at
least
three steps towards black world tendency
if your icon
is this color or darker it's time to go
hunting
when you kill it you will go three steps
back towards white
which in most cases means the world will
at least be back to where it started
from here play in soul form and then go
back to killing bosses
in boletaria the demon is found in the
third stage
past where you would have found the
official's cap take the stairs on the
right
past the two guards and there it is in
stonefang it's found on the first level
just activate the elevator past the
falling boulders
and you'll find it at the bottom in
latria progress through the second stage
until you find yurt's cell
that takes you down into the swamp and
look for it down there
in the shrine of storms kill the first
reaper to open a passageway on the left
go through the secret entrance avoid the
black skeletons and you'll find the
demon further on
lastly in the second level of the valley
turn left to go deeper into the swamp
right before you hit the village with
the filthy woman
if your world is four steps deep into
black world tendency
that means it's pure black where special
named black phantoms will appear
these drop special loot but they're also
very difficult to defeat
if you manage it you'll go a step back
towards white world tendency and you'll
get a cool item too
honestly world tendency kind of deserves
an entire video so
stay tuned for that and if you
appreciate all the help here maybe
consider buying some of my merch
you might remember ages ago i launched a
design called fate
on teespring which looks quite similar
to yurt's armor i think so maybe check
that one out
and i'm also excited to announce a new
design called valahat
which is printed on champion hoodies and
champion tease
i'm sure you're familiar with that brand
the reason i chose this design for that
brand was
because the design is inspired by the
vala heart weapon from dark souls 3
and some of you might get the
association you get this weapon from the
champion grave tender it's a subtle
souls reference
like all my merches so most people in
public shouldn't recognize the gaming
reference
unless they're an avid souls fan that's
the goal
but thank you for watching and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you